well joining me now via phone call
because he would prefer not to be seen
on camera is Jeffrey Epstein's brother
Mark
Epstein Mark Epstein thank you very much
indeed for joining me um let me first of
all ask you what did you know about your
brother and it's an obvious question but
you are his relative his sibling um when
this all came out about him were you as
shocked as everybody else or did you
have concerns about him well back in 20
06 when he first got into trouble he
told me that he was getting into trouble
you know for what he was doing and uh so
so I knew from early on what was
happening I uh yeah so he told me early
on did you know the scale of it I mean
obviously he had that conviction he
served time in in prison but the sheer
scale I made it real clear I made it
real clear I'm not discussing anything
about my brother's charges against him I
have nothing to do with that I wasn't
involved I have no more information the
only thing I'm interested in discussing
is the circumstances surrounding his
murder okay well you say it's a murder
obviously it was ruled as suicide why do
you believe that's not
true well first the the actual
pathologist who did the
autopsy uh did not determine it was a
suicide they couldn't they said it
looked more like a homicide but on the
death on the initial death certificate
on cause of death it said pending
meaning pending further investigation
which is proper and then a few days
later you know Bill bar claims it was a
suicide and then the chief pathologist
of New York who did not see the body
claims was a suicide so the point the
question becomes what investigating was
done in a matter of days to make them
come out with that determination and it
turns out that because it was called a
suicide it doesn't seem to have been an
investigation because if you declare
somebody died by Suicide there's really
nothing to investigate you the only
questions about a suicide is how did
they do it did they hang themselves did
they shoot themselves did they jump out
of a window and that's the pretty
obvious answer at the time of the death
so there's no investigation was done the
EMTs that went to the prison were never
questioned the hospital Personnel were
never questioned we can't seem to find
the medical records
we can't get the 911 call if this was a
suicide why are all these things
hidden and why I mean obviously make
that ridiculous
statement right let's talk about the
night that your brother died he was
found hanged what is it about what
happened that night that well yeah well
okay he that's what was reported so tell
me why you think that what happened that
night is so
suspicious okay first of all for four
years we were trying to find out what
position his body was in when he was
found because that that's very Telly uh
but we couldn't find out because they
moved his body after he was found uh to
the infirmary of the prison when the
EMTs were called and they got to the
prison he was already dead in the
infirmary understand something he had
been dead for at least two hours before
he was found that's what the autopsy
showed and that's not a question that's
a fact he could have been de for six
hours but at least two now they said in
the doj report that finally came out
that he was found hanging they said he
was in a seated position with his legs
extended in front of him and when he was
had tied to the top bunk and when they
either cut him or tore him down his
buttocks was an inch and an inch and a
half off the ground which if you picture
that it means
basically his entire body body weight or
the bulk of his body weight was hanging
by the neck yes there was probably some
weight on his feet at the end of his
legs but the bulk of his body was
hanging now the mark on his neck left by
the
ligature is in the middle of his neck
and go straight back if he was hanging
as they said the ligature would have
slid up high up under his chin and then
went up back sort of behind his ears up
to the whatever he was tied to
so the ligature mark on his neck is
inconsistent with the way they describe
them and another important thing is that
when you die when a person dies you know
their blood isn't circulating anymore
and what happens The Blood starts to
settle in the body to the lowest point
gravity just takes the blood you know
through the tissue so you get a pooling
of the blood under the skin which which
is why they tell you to never move a
dead body because they can tell tell a
lot of things if you find a dead body
laying on its face and the back has its
lividity with cool blood that means the
body died on its back and somebody
eventually turned it over so if you
picture the way they describe Jeffrey as
hanging well he should have vividity in
in the back of his legs and in his
buttocks which was the lowest parts of
his body okay if he let me ask you this
if he didn't take his own life who do
you think took it
who killed him in your estimation it's a
good question you know Bill bar said
that no one would end out of the Tia so
he concluded it was a suicide but there
were something like 11 or 12 other
prisoners on that tier that could have
went in and killed him now if another
prisoner killed him it's s of why would
they go to the extent to cover it up you
know it's like if if you remember the
case of Whitey buer he was in prison and
he got killed by three other inmates
well they got the guys and they
prosecuted him for killing whitey buer
in jail if it was just another prisoner
that killed Jeff why would they not just
find out who it was and prosecute him
for murder there doesn't seem to
be a reason to cover that up also we
can't get a list of who were those
prisoners that were already on the tier
we know I know one was the kagon who was
Jeff you know cellmate for a while now
the question becomes who was on the tier
that night
when were they put there and when were
they transferred out because I was told
that after the death a number of
prisoners would transferred off of that
tier to other places so let me ask you
mark let me ask you do you do you
believe obviously Jeffrey your brother
had uh relationships friendships with
many many of the most rich famous
powerful people in the world do you
believe that you know if let's take this
this Theory to uh a conclusion here do
you think that one of those people who
may have had a vested interest in
shutting him up and not talking about
what he knew about them potentially may
have played a part in his
death yes that's what I think happened
and then you have to question out of the
Rich and powerful people he knew who
would have the ability to pull something
like this off that's another question
who would have the ability to PL
somebody in there if that's the way it
was done who would have the ability for
the to have the justice department come
up with this you know pardon the
language his [__] report you know
the justice department report it just
says that it was declared dead by the uh
pathologist but that's not true it was
it was declared undetermined by the
pathologist that did the actual report
and then for some
reason yeah you you've claimed uh Mark
Epstein that your brother had
information on Donald Trump and Bill
Clinton
that was so inury that the 2016 election
would have been cancelled if that
information had come
out what was that information that's
wait wait that's incorrect What Jeffrey
told me during the 2016 election we were
just discussing the election just two
brothers talking about current things uh
he what he said was that if he said what
he knew about both candidates they'd
have to cancel the election so he was
talking about Donald Trump and he was
talking about Hillary because Bill
wasn't running at that point in time and
and and Jeffrey used to sometimes tell
me things about people he was with
whatever I never heard Jeffrey say
anything bad about Bill Clinton Jeffrey
always liked Bill Clinton he like Bill
Clinton so I I don't think that uh you
know again he he didn't say he had
information on Bill Clinton he he
mentioned the candidate so I want to
keep the record straight I like to keep
facts out there not speculation what
information what information do you
think he had on Donald Trump for example
that could have uh
disqualified specific inform I don't
know any specific information but I've
also heard Jeffrey say that he stopped
hanging out with Donald Trump when he
realized Trump was a crook that's on
tape I I heard a videotape interview
with Jeff and he
said that he stopped hanging out with
Donald Trump when he realized Trump was
a
crook do you believe that there are do
do you believe do you do you believe
that there are these videotapes which
came out of in the unsealed document
yesterday that there are videotapes uh
which apparently were from cameras that
your brother put in place recording
famous people from prince Andrew to Bill
Clinton to Richard Branson and others
having sex on tape do you believe that
you know I've heard those stories and
it's sort of like doesn't matter if I
believe it or not I don't know so again
I I shy away from speculating on things
I have no backs on okay I I was told by
somebody who supposedly knew that there
were not cameras
in the New York house you know I know
there were cameras that around the
entryways and for security I was told
there was no cameras inside but again I
don't know if that's how reliable that I
thought it was reliable you know and I
don't have any reason to to doubt it but
again I don't want to speculate so so I
have no knowledge of any tapes or
anything yeah okay markstein I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much you're welcome love you well I'm
joined Now by Gloria OLED who represents
over 20 of Jeffrey Epstein's victims
Gloria uh what did you make of that
conversation with Mark
Epstein well I like the fact that he was
fact-based I do think there is quite a
bit of uh rumor conspiracy theory uh
filling the vacuum of you know the facts
that didn't come out as soon as they
might have uh so I still think that
there are a lot of questions about
whether it was a suicide whether it was
a
homicide uh whether it was some kind of
natural death I I don't know it I know
there have been you know an report I
Believe by the uh you know many
investigations which decided or
concluded that it was a suicide but I
think there's still an open question I
remember seeing Jeffrey Epstein the last
time he appeared in court in New York
and I know that many of the victims that
I rep presented 20 that I represent many
of those 20 were hoping and expecting
that there would be uh other hearings
other you know in the prosecution that
was taking place of him and they were so
thrilled that finally there might be
some justice in the case in the criminal
justice system of course uh his death uh
ended in in a way that was and at a time
that was so unexpected and was
devastating
to many of the victims who hope to be
able to confront him in that court of
law in federal court in New
York what people who don't know Jeffrey
FC just know all these rumor mill stuff
and some of it's true some of it is you
know it's hard to really piece together
the reality here about him what is your
belief about Jeffrey Epstein
Gloria well definitely I called him I
call him a child sex abuser uh a sex
trafficker of underage girls and uh
that's what of course uh galain Maxwell
was charged with and was convicted in
federal court uh I by the way I never
use the word pedophile because that
means a lover of children and a man who
exploits and hurts and traffics uh and
uh you know does what he did to underage
girls and so often to adult women as
well is not a lover of children is not a
lover of women he's a
manipulator uh and uh he's a a a sex
predator there's a lot of ongoing
speculation about Prince Andrew's uh
friendship with Epstein and what he knew
or didn't know uh the bottom line is he
paid Virginia JRA uh reported $1 million
to settle a case with he said he was
never going to settle
uh what what do you read into that I
mean is there any way in a normal world
that somebody would pay someone that
amount of money to stop a case
proceeding if they didn't have something
to hide I've done
countless uh settlements after
litigation or what we call
pre-litigation
and the accused person never uh admits
that he did it but when we we do it uh
you know we present a great deal of
evidence to the accused to through his
lawyers and uh and then there is a
process often a mediation process with a
retired judge or a professional mediator
where there's
conversation which is really a
negotiation and there's a result so
bottom line I can't say whether he did
it or not but it certainly raised is a
question if he paid
substantial uh millions of dollars to
resolve and settle the
case gor roid as always great to have
you on the program thank you very
much thank
you but on S next I'll be getting more
on this story with my panel including 's
former lawyer Alan
[Music]
DZ welcome back to un censored from Los
Angeles let's get more now on the
bombshell court documents about
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein's powerful
friends joining me now as his former
lawyer and the author Alan dtz the
investigative journalist Vicky Ward and
Fox News host Tommy Len well welcome to
all of you Alan d let me start with you
you've obviously your name has has
appeared in these unsealed documents in
various places um what should we read
into these documents there's so much
claim counter claim denial suspicious
silence in some cases what should the
public make of
it well first I want every document to
come out every single one I want every
videotape to be revealed I hope there
are videotapes of every single sexual
encounter that anybody ever had in any
property of Jeffrey Epstein and I hereby
wave any right of privacy because I know
I did nothing wrong I had sex with one
woman from the day I met jaffre abene
till the day he died my wife and these
tapes have revealed exculpatory material
Sharon churcher for example there were
emails that show that she put my name
into the head of Virginia gofy she said
although we know dtz didn't do anything
wrong he didn't we didn't we couldn't
prove anything against him uh it would
be a good name for you to put in your
book because he's famous he represented
Claus vulo a movie was made about him
and then she put me in her book as
somebody she did not have sex with so
you know these disclosed materials have
helped people who are falsely accused by
me they don't help people who have been
truthfully accused there's another woman
named Sarah Ransom who also now it's
been disclosed that she claimed to have
sex tapes of Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump and now she's admitted that she
made the whole thing up so it's a very
good thing that these tapes and these
pictures and these emails have come out
I want more to come out there are FBI
reports I've seen an FBI report but it's
redacted there are tape recordings that
are relevant to the Innocence or guilt
of people who are accused the one thing
we shouldn't do is engage in McCarthyism
we shouldn't do what McCarthy did he
held up lists and said if your name is
on the list you're guilty my name is on
the list of course it is I was his
lawyer but my name is on the list in an
exculpatory way and so I'm very pleased
that these materials have come out I
want more to come out we filed a brief
the other day in court demanding even
more information to come out because all
the information will prove that I did
nothing wrong I was his lawyer if you
don't like that well then complain about
our legal system but I never had any
improper relation with anybody connected
to Jeffrey Epstein or anyone else you
mentioned Sarah Ransom there she is one
of Epstein's victims and she made the
claims about the existence of these sex
tapes then she did retract them but
interestingly she's now come out and
doubled down on her original claim in an
interview with my old show good morning
in Britain let's take a look there are
videos that
exist the people that know they
exist um I'm sure very frightened of
them being released so how do you know
then that Epstein had cameras on the
island it's no secret that everything
was
recorded multiple victims have come
forward confirming my account along with
others I've also seen recordings in his
office well Vicky Ward you you actually
met uh Sarah Ransom uh it's hard to know
where the truth lies given that she has
said once set of uh claims then she's
retracted them and now she's doubled
down on the original claims what do you
think well I think if you listen to her
language just there appears she's not
quite doubling down on these specifics
of the original claims she's just saying
there are tapes she's not saying
specifically of who I think look Sarah
Ransom in 2022 published a memoir called
silence no more which you know will have
had to have gone through pretty rigorous
legal vetting and factchecking and none
of the specific allegations that we read
uh in the document done yesterday are in
there and Sarah Ransom was not uh a
witness or an accuser taking the stand
in Gillen Maxwell's criminal trial nor
was Virginia Roberts
nonetheless
the pattern of behavior that both of
them
described did form the
backbone of the substance being
discussed at that trial and I think that
is why it's important for other victims
were the were the victims who took the
stand in Gillen Maxwell's trial they
also by the way got things wrong when
they were first interviewed by the FBI
uh they then either forgot it or or or
or had to sort of say they'
misremembered it when when under
cross-examination it happens with
stories of extreme sexual abuse it does
all of this does make it really hard for
journalists like us to sort out the
wheat from the chaff and this story you
know the whole the Jeffrey Epstein story
Still Remains a huge mystery because you
know in these latest filings we get this
lurid picture into endless depravity the
man seems to have had so much sexual
activity a day it leaves you wondering
when he had time to do anything else and
if he didn't have time to do anything
else then why were all these really
important powerful world leaders
floating around him there are lots of uh
questions here that are still
outstanding yeah I mean Tommy luren
looking at this in totality you've got a
guy that was clearly a Serial abuser
often of underage girls doing it in
plain sight whilst also maintaining a
position as financier and socialite
friend of the most rich powerful famous
people on Earth and yet the only person
so far who's been brought to Justice
over any of this is his former fixer
gillain Maxwell not a single man has
been brought to account here despite the
Welter of evidence that they're all
there
but time a lot of these people what do
you think of
it well I'll tell you this money is
power and we know from looking at
Hollywood especially over the last 10
years we've had more Revelations thanks
to the me too movement which is very
selective by the way that pedophiles and
predators protect one another because
Hollywood and places of power DC
included are crawling with predators and
pedophiles that's why it's taken so long
for us to get this information that's
why so many have protected not only but
have protected the logs that have
protected these document dumps from
coming out we get redacted versions We
Get sensationalism with names being
thrown around but will we ever really
get to the bottom of it will we ever
really get to the bottom of what
happened to Jeffrey Epstein a lot of us
are not confident we ever will because
we understand what I said predators and
pedophiles protect one another and the
fact that Hollywood and the elites have
been coddling this man and this
information for so long tells you
everything that you need to know about
the inner workings the dungeons that
make up Hollywood DC and political
Elites around the world they protect
each other Alan do you believe that
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself or do you
believe as his brother said earlier that
he was murdered well I don't know for
sure I think he had a motive to kill
himself he couldn't stand the idea of
spending the rest of his life in prison
but the circumstances demand
investigation I don't believe if he
committed suicide he did it by himself
he would have had to pay off I think
some of the guards I think some of the
guards have been disciplined everybody
who has any culpability should be held
responsible I'm on the same side as the
victims in this case I want all the
evidence to come out so that the true
victims are Vindicated but I also want
the evidence to come out that shows that
there are some credibility questions
about people like Ransom and others
you've said that prince Andrew shouldn't
have settled with Virginia je freay A
Roberts obviously uh why do you believe
that well even if everything they said
about him was true she was over the age
of consent um she bragged to people
about how wonderful it was and to pay
millions of dollars for that a a jury
would never have come back that way and
I think he could have won the case on
legal grounds but I suspect that he was
concerned about what would happen during
a deposition not about necessarily the
person who accused him but about his
whole life because depositions are wide
open I think it was a terrible mistake
for prince Andrew to have uh settled the
case I wish he could reopen it because I
don't think there was jurisdiction in
the federal court I don't think that
there was uh the statute of limitations
were satisfied there are all kinds of
legal issues that he could have W on but
I suspect his mother did not want the
embarrassment that would have come out
had he sat for a deposition okay Vicki
um youve what extensively for Vanity
Fair one of the emails that came out was
between Virginia Frey and Sharon
churcher suggesting that Bill Clinton
had stormed into the Vanity Fair offices
and threatened them not to write a sex
trafficking expose of Epstein do you
have any knowledge of that do we know if
that actually happened did Clinton do
that I've never heard that and I know
that Gren Carter who was the editor at
the time has categorically denied it you
know what did happen and and what I
think sort of probably made its way in a
convoluted ultim timately inaccurate
form to Virginia um many years later
writing that email was that Jeffrey
Epstein appeared in the Vanity Fair
offices um and uh had a conversation the
contents of which I've I've never
learned but it was while my article on
him was being fact checked and supposed
to be closing and all I know remember I
was on bed rest uh pregnant with my
twins at the time I was not in the
office was that at the 11th uh the
allegator of Maria and Annie farmer were
cut from the article um so I think that
somehow Virginia Lear a version of what
had happened that was that was
wrong Tommy finally look at the politics
of this normally you'd say one side
could latch onto it the other side could
latch on to it it's the problem here is
you've got prominent figures on both
sides you've got Republican icons like
Donald Trump you've got Democrat icons
like the Clinton and so on is this a
kind of situation where actually a stain
on all their houses no one can really
get political gain from this
Scandal yeah I think that you know this
as well as I do peers that if Donald
Trump were implicated in anything
illegal or anything nefarious that would
be the first thing that would be
explored to the 20th degree because
Donald Trump can't breathe without them
inditing him so I think actually Donald
Trump's being name being mentioned but
nothing really Beyond mention I think
that goes to show that Donald Trump is
probably very innocent of doing anything
nefarious or anything awful because if
he had that would be you know another
stain on him and the media runs to do
that in every opportunity if they could
I think we both know they absolutely
would Tommy lren Alan dotz Vicky W thank
you all very much indeed this Scandal
will run and run we may never actually
get to the truth sadly but I appreciate
you
joining